[Music]
today's question comes from david in
oregon david writes i've been paying the
bills but not doing a proper budget
since my wife and i got married i
thought i could do it and we coasted up
by for about 10 years then kids came
time flew by and we accumulated 30
thousand dollars in debt i never made my
spouse part of the process and held her
off so she didn't have to feel the
financial burden
she has a quote unquote feeling that
something isn't right when i won't let
her see our finances
and she's right i recently read one of
dave's tweets look at you using twitter
to help people i didn't know that was
possible it said if you're in a
committed relationship you've got to
play with all of your cards face up how
do we start over and do it right this
time
this is a moment this is it one of those
cool marriages a really great question i
love this question
so dave in my life
when i've i've had several of these in
my marriage over 20 years
it always starts with me saying
we need to have a discussion
and i need to i need to
invite you into some hard stuff that's
going on in my heart mine my actions
whatever and i start with i'm sorry i've
been living this way and i haven't
brought you along i've left you out i've
excluded you whatever the thing is
and
i want to invite you in to help make
this right and she's very right to feel
betrayed she's very right or her
feelings are gonna be her feelings but
it starts with somebody
turning the lights on turn the music off
and saying i was wrong and i'm sorry
let's start here
yeah
and i gotta tell you though i mean i've
walked couples through this
and sometimes i played marriage
counselor for five minutes in the middle
of a coaching session on money
uh in this
and if he will just i got 99 percent of
the time if if dude you got the perfect
heart she's got the right heart actually
both of you do for this for this to be
successful and so
i would just say look i have screwed
this up i'm sorry
the reason i screwed it up was it
started off with i was just going to
take care of it i was going to man up so
you didn't have to worry about it
and then it got out of control and i was
ashamed
that i didn't
do it right
and that caused me to even become
more guarded of it and i should have
just brought the whole thing to you and
we should have worked on it together and
i really screwed up but i screwed up
because i was trying to
be the man and carry this for you and
that's not the right way to be a man by
the way
and i was trying and then when it fell
apart and i couldn't do it then i was
ashamed of myself and i didn't want to
didn't want to reveal to you that i had
screwed up because i felt i felt stupid
and so if he just says that which is
what he said right but if he just says
that to her she's going to be really
forgiving oh man and
this usually when i see a couple like
this there's something underneath it
which
there's something about the way they
communicate in this home that she
doesn't like so if this is
my wife
she will
not say hey i've got a feeling she will
insert herself into this process right
so there's something about it could be
that they've been married five years and
you've been married 20. that's well
they've been married first five years
sharon would have been this now sharon
would be like what
it's going very similar here it's
different now yeah after 40 years you
know we we kind of cut through the bull
you know so
those one hour conversations are six six
seconds yeah it's like
not i have a feeling it's like ah you're
scheming and scamming what the crap's
going on
but something here is gonna have to
change in how they do because this is
just gonna show up money's gonna show up
with kids it's gonna show whatever yeah
let's let's come up with a new way of
doing business of loving each other and
and here here's the lesson that you get
out of this and you learn it through the
money lens and it will affect your whole
marriage to your point and the lesson
that you get out of it that's so
beautiful is this that everything you do
is going to be better when you do it
together right
instead of you trying to give her the
gift of her not having to worry right
that is not a real gift and every time
that's a falsehood have a feeling uh hey
something's not right
develop a language that y'all can ask
each other that question yeah it just
does away with it right right away just
goes away it's poof
you deal with it you move on oh and by
the way this also tells us that your
wife has really really good intuition
yep and so the next time she has a
feeling
about the car salesman but you think you
want to buy the truck anyway you need to
get off the lot yep because her feelings
are probably pretty intuitive probably
pretty accurate yeah it might be god
speaking through her i've learned that
the hard way yeah
if sharon says sharon's southern so she
says she it's a seven syllable word i
got a bad feeling and if she gets a bad
feeling and i go against it cost me 10
grand at least
i just quit doing it i just don't go
against those feelings they're expensive
i've been wrong almost every single time
i just i mean we have to get on the same
page and i don't violate that i mean
i'll question her i'm like was it last
night's pizza i mean why are you having
a feeling but but she's like no no this
guy i just think he's a bad guy i don't
know what it is but i can't put my
finger on it but i got a bad feeling oh
geez we're getting away from that guy oh
he's playing asap gonna find out later
what happened with him